you been in all these movies in so many
movies you've so effectively played
these sort of badass characters and then
it's nice and refreshing to see that on
Twitter
you're very self-effacing you're very
light you post these very funny pictures
of yourself using different like you put
this up you do a lot of that on Twitter
it's what's funny about that issue after
a bad night was something [ __ ] now we
got a hot mi fine man I got a lot of my
mind yeah you know I'm writing and
everything both I'm gonna own that
you're an author now you know I'm
curious about something you posted this
picture of you and Justin Bieber
together I think you're in a club I
don't understand you're wearing a shirt
he is not wearing a shirt were you
tempted any point to remove odor Wesley
what was going what was going on there I
think that was the Cannes Film Festival
and we just happened to be at the same
you know nightlife spot right in time
and this will turns out you know they
were playing the reggae and I love
reggae and they asked me you know come
up on stage and say hello to my friend
and next thing I know they gave me a mic
and when they gave me the mic Victoria
gave myself naturally sure you want to
do a reggae reggae rap is that what you
did your mom weird Wesley go what's
happening whistling I caught him Wesley
- dun Dada my generator
he's West lion leo
[Applause]
minute yesterday oh my god I'm on also
now oh yeah you got to get the free
breakfast at Denny's
you